hockey has become such a such a huge
sport here in las vegas
it attracts a ton of attention lots of
las vegas and even those passing through
ron futrell caught up with one of those
entertainers who says
following the nights is no joke
well hi everybody a special treat for
you tonight we're going to have our
hockey expert ian bagg with us
he's canadian he's funny oh by the way
he brings some real star power
to our edition of striking gold if you
turn around
it's ryan reeves and that's the saddest
part about hockey
guys move but fans can't afford to get
in new jersey
you were such a hit with the fans when
you came out here to vegas
they love see they love seeing you at
t-mobile arena
that's had to have hurt to not have that
interaction that you
i saw with the fans i miss it big time i
miss it it's
crazy we did that we did the in front of
the
the t-mobile we just had so much fun
teasing the fans and them teasing me
and and getting to see how much people
in vegas
loved hockey that was one of the things
and how great it was i don't know if you
remember like there was people wearing
half
uh half the visiting team and half the
vegas team had those jerseys made and
stuff like that
and i just loved it and it was so much
fun and then boom no way
how have you been surviving this i mean
your comedy and you
you seem to thrive so much on that
interpersonal reaction
uh it's been tough you know i've just
been yelling at people from my balcony
it's
basically how i'm doing how i've been
doing interviews as they walk by how are
you doing what do you think about things
and they just answer
and it's just a good time but i i've
been doing shows uh via zoom
i've also been doing outdoor shows i
started i think in
like august july going to uh some places
on the beach and
some people had places in their backyard
where they invite some friends over and
everybody be distance and we do stand up
there a couple comics and stuff like
that
but uh and i've traveled a couple times
i went to alaska
uh in october and they had no idea there
was even a pandemic when i got there
so that was so i just told them nobody's
let them know yet
i'm the only one wearing a mask i'm
walking around wearing a mask and i was
loving it because people i'm not going
to look like a dummy i'm like you got a
mullet you're fine
it's not going to hurt you don't just
wear the mask so
yeah but uh yeah it's it's been it's
been
interesting i've traveled a couple times
uh places some places have been more
open than a lot of places but uh just
surviving and uh
getting you know what uh ron i traveled
so much
i had no idea how great my home life was
so
it's kind of been a blessing i've gotten
to know my dogs and my wife
much better my wife actually likes me
it's it's i had no idea
yeah you found one that's good
yeah yeah it's awesome i have no idea
the lady that lived with me we were
married i had no idea
you just stopped by come in and out and
say hi
i just drop off money and leave tell me
how
okay caesars you were going to open up
caesar's the convention center uh
the convention yeah so i was doing this
tour
where i was going from city to city
and i was in the back of a of a
18-wheeler that they had turned into a
theater and i would tell them all about
this caesar's
new convention center that they were
about to open and the first thing they
were going to do in there was the nfl
draft that was they were going to do
so they had the combine set up there was
going to be set up outside and then the
draft was going to happen inside
and then it was going to be voila
there's this new convention center
and i remember uh when we started was
january and i just remember i said the
guy that was in charge
have you heard about this virus this
thing goes yeah that's what we're
finding
april april's a long ways away we'll
still have the draft here
yeah he said everything's gonna be fine
nothing good yeah so it was like i mean
i remember he's like you were right
we're not gonna it's not gonna happen
you were looking forward to coming to
see the raiders play here i
i wanted to go to that building so bad
and when you build a
huge like noah's ark but all in black
you're like
oh boy there's going to be trouble and
you want to go
look inside it and yeah and i just i
just look it looked like such a
fantastic building
and i wanted to go see a game there so
bad just just the weather
you know everything and just this
excitement from the people
because you've see we've seen what we've
done with the uh with the golden knights
so i'm wondering what's going to go on
there
and they already have a following
because they're the raiders so i was
like what kind of excitement is that
all right thank you there ian now ian
bagg is returning to las vegas
this week the outdoor comedy series at
desert pines golf course on east bonanza
that's this friday
march 28th bring your nine iron and
watch a comedy show i'm ron futrell
eight sports now